how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about all things superhero
everything marvel and of course
everything relating to the mcu we have a
lot of awesome information
about the falcon and the winter soldier
information that's really good because
it tells us the status of the falcon and
the winter soldier but also could
possibly tell us when to expect the
teaser trailer and if it's going to be
out this year
currently right now it's unknown whether
the falcon and the winter soldier will
air in 2020 or in 2021 but it is
supposed to be the first
project coming from phase four ever
since black widow got pushed back to
november 4th so we'll talk about this
new report talk about when to expect a
teaser trailer and the release date for
the falcon and the winter soldier in
this video
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu updates and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
hawkeye funko pop all you gotta do is
subscribe
like the video leave a comment down
below so today's news is coming from
thedirect.com
which is also a part of mcu direct and
in their report they said
the direct has exclusively obtained a
production document that confirms the
falcon and the wonder soldier
is scheduled to resume production in
atlanta georgia in early september
this document was released today so this
means cameras are set to officially be
rolling by next week
bearing no further delays or problems
this is some of the most exciting news
that we've heard in a pretty long time
unfortunately it's been pretty stale
with recent news because marvel studios
for the most part has pretty much been
shut down things have been delayed
projects have gotten new release dates
but now it appears that the falcon and
the winter soldier are going to resume
filming again
this week now this is awesome news
because that means we're going to start
to get a lot of new information
again but most importantly if production
resumes and they get everything back on
track with the falcon and the winter
soldier
that means two different things one is
that they can start to finish
a teaser trailer if it's not already
finished and release it knowing that
they're actually going to rap on filming
and the show is actually going to come
out at a specific time
and two that specific time the release
date for the series will be revealed
if filming resumes again this week that
means that they should be done with
everything that they need to do
by the end of fall and if this happens
that means that they could definitely
release the falcon in the winter soldier
this year in 2020 and if that happens
and it kind of looks like it will happen
that means that we could receive a
teaser trailer the first
official teaser trailer for this show
this month or next
and that's really what everybody is
waiting for right now we haven't
received anything official from marvel
studios in a pretty long time but now
that everything is resuming again it
looks like the falcon and the winter
soldier is going to be our best hope for
getting some content soon so the falcon
and the winter soldier is going to
resume production and filming
this week once filming begins if we find
out any new information about falcon and
the winter soldier i'll be sure to
update everybody so be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news don't forget to like the
video and let me know how excited you
are about the falcon and the winter
soldier in the comments down below for
live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you